[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
la communauté paris-saclay s'inscrit
dans la semaine européenne de la
mobilité et organise un certain nombre
d'événements à destination du grand
public pour faire se rencontrer à la
fois les opérateurs de mobilité
transporteurs mais également les
associations est allé à la rencontre du
grand public cette année comme l'année
dernière on a souhaité organiser une
journée particulière autour du vélo et
des mobilités alternatives ont
co-organise avec l'université paris
saclay pour aller en particulier rend
compte du public étudiant mais également
du public des salariés des chercheurs du
campus urbain paris saclay on propose
toute une journée qui permet à la fois
de renseigner grand public sur les
actions en faveur du vélo
porté par l'agglomération et
l'université pour permettre aux
associations locales investis sur le
vélo de faire parler d'eux et de
rencontrer le public mais également de
proposer une vente de vélos solidaire
d'assez grande ampleur puisque on a à
peu près 60 70 vélos mis en vente par la
recyclerie sportives à savoir que le
même événement était organisé ce matin
même également sur le campus de
l'université paris sud avec sollicite
une association d'insertion dans le
domaine du vélo cet après-midi étudiants
salariés et cetera pourront acheter des
vélos de réemploi est également
participé à un atelier d'entretien
réparation des vélos qui veulent venir
avec leur vélo personnel mais également
gravage bicycode pour lutter contre le
vol
le but ici pour l'université
c'est de promouvoir
les déplacements par mode bout donc le
vélo bien sûr et puis aussi les
déplacements piétons but 7 6 1 donc ça
c'est un des premiers buts et un second
but c'est vraiment de construire un
événement fédérateur tous ensemble c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui on retrouve de
nombreux partenaires différents à la
fois institutionnelle donc bien sûr la
communauté paris saclay avec qui on
reporte l'événement mais aussi le pea
centrale supélec qui nous accueillent
ici
l'université paris sud qui accueille un
événement similaire dans la vallée et
puis tout un tas de partenaires
associatif donc des associations du
territoire à la fois évidente avec
notamment un pacte centrale supélec
l'association de développement durable
des étudiants sont respectées mais aussi
des associations comme une mobylette
project le collectif action création ou
culturels qui viennent ici pour pour
parler du vélo et à organiser ensemble
une grande fête du vélo